on prime crime chickasaw county 911
it's a scene straight from a nightmare
what i took away was
the pain and the trauma of the first
responder that person's life is never
going to be the same again and all eyes
on a concerning couple
were you at any
not time fault i didn't really even
challenge cheyenne in the interview we
had no idea it was far worse than that
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most high
profile and memorable true crime cases
a death in an iowa home leads to many
questions and a horrifying outcome
county 911
it's august 30th 2017 in iowa
zachary keane a father of two young
children calls 9-1-1 and reveals a
terrifying discovery
okay what's going on
round nine my girlfriend went to
feed our son and
then about
11 or
11 30 shouldn't check on him and
he was gone
gone meaning he died
it's this statement that would begin the
investigation into the death of
four-month-old sterling keane who would
be found dead in his swing
what i took away was
the pain and the trauma of the first
responder that person's life is never
going to be the same again after seeing
that close-up and having been someone as
a former prosecutor who went to a a
plethora of crime scenes right but to
see a helpless child in that state is
just a whole new level she would have
checked on her head murdered her cry or
whatever and she passed away
typically
if a person is going to dial 9-1-1 after
their child is dead they would be
panicking
or they would be in shock
in this case zach acted what i like to
call desperately casual
and this is a red flag his neighbor was
actually the one that had to tell him to
call 9-1-1 because he was just standing
outside of their apartment complex
so this was not rational decision making
when responders showed up that zachary
was muttering
he was casual in his demeanor he was
quiet there was no tear to be seen it
was later argued that he was in shock
in this moment
but shock doesn't look like this it's
particularly interesting what keane says
about the potential cause of death
i don't know if it's done in death
syndrome or why zach's comments about
sudden infant death could be a viable
consideration whenever somebody loses a
child especially a young child like
sterling that's something that we would
consider
police though need more answers
hours after sterling's death special
agent chris callaway spoke with cheyenne
harris keane's girlfriend and the mother
of sterling as well as the couple's
daughter two-year-old nala
do you remember putting stripping in the
swing
there was a detachment when talking
about sterling she lit up when she was
talking about her daughter
when she was talking about her
her dog
um
but
but the the comments about sterling uh
there was
maybe a coldness
every time being crapped it was straight
liquid
i actually had a diaper where there was
no crab in it and i was amazed
yeah
how could you tell when he was
uncomfortable
close i guess okay
that's pretty much all intended
harris explains the moments leading up
to finding sterling dead
so nala wakes up around noon what
happens next i got up and changed her
diaper
went to the bathroom myself fed her
and then i got her set up in the movie
room to watch movies a little bit
what did your feet hurt do you remember
cookies
that's okay
i even started thinking
[Music]
callaway goes through different possible
scenarios no illegal drugs in the house
or no medication that you know of that
that sterling could have gotten into or
found or
ingested
initially you go into these child death
investigations with an open mind open
mind to it could be something medical it
could be something uh criminal while
crossing off these potential options
what does become clear
is something feels a bit off when your
phone's driving
did um
did you take him onto the swing or did
he is he still on the swing
he was still missing okay
then what happens after he gets that
i don't think she really understood the
full gravity
of what she was facing and what and and
what had happened to her
coming up
new details come to light that change
everything but i didn't know
the the scope and magnitude of
sterling's condition and so she's
describing these as very matter of fact
[Music]
zach said that it's
not my fault is
it unusual
to go
that long without checking
in 2017 iowa police are called to the
residence of zachary keen and his
girlfriend cheyenne harris
they find the dead body of the couple's
four-month-old son sterling lying in his
swing
it's not immediately clear how sterling
died yet when harris speaks with special
agent chris calloway some of the pieces
of the puzzle start to fill in
well just tell me like
sterling's schedule
he normally was able to sleep through
the night with no problem
where was sterling
your next bedroom in the swing okay so
sterling was in the swing but the swing
wasn't moving at that point
okay
is it possible that this couple just
accidentally forgot about their baby son
in his swing would that have been around
what time would that have been when you
got him the bottle and changed him
like i'm honestly not sure what time
when was zach's last contact with
[Applause]
how exactly could that happen this
becomes all the more complicated when
you dig into the lives of harris and
keane overall zach and cheyenne
they were just an irresponsible couple
they would do meth together they came
together based on their drug use
not love he continued to use
methamphetamine after sterling was born
when sterling was born they found
methamphetamine
in his blood drug use in general affects
a person's decision making and can make
it more difficult for a person to think
clearly it can increase distractibility
reduce motor speed overall when you're
saying yes to using meth you're saying
no to being a good parent after
everything that's been happened and
all i can think about is death yeah well
and you're juggling a ton of stuff i
mean a lot of things going on diane has
been a mother before
and so she should have known how to care
for her child
zach made anywhere between 35 000 to
forty five thousand dollars a year
he found money to spend on
methamphetamine but did not have the
money allegedly to spend on the special
formula that their baby needed their
friends would come over but they had no
idea that they even had a baby so
overall these were two people who were
not proud to have a small baby
does he
does he help you at all with child care
exactly no yeah
he doesn't have a stomach for um
diaper changing
his viewpoint was very much that the man
goes out and goes to work and does not
have anything to do with the home front
that basically i'm bringing home the
money you take care of the child and you
take care of the house and that's why he
was just not engaged when it came to
parenting young sterling
the issues in their parenting became
even more apparent when we learned about
sterling's birth during a party spend
all day
trying to go to the path and cramps got
worse and worse and worse
pushing feels
not the way that it normally does i go
to stand up and there's a bullet oh my
god
there's a head so i sit back down on the
toilet scream
for zach he came out in the water and he
just eyes popped open he was just
scaring me
we wrapped him up and waited for the
ambulance
the mother literally didn't realize she
was in labor and she was at a party and
literally gave birth in the bathtub of
the people's house she'd just been at
the party let's kind of start with that
and then you know secondly obviously
that lack of awareness about your body
and the fact that you're you know going
into labor
you know that's already setting the
child up for a very problematic life i
can't help but feel that i said
something differently
or that i should have checked on him
is it is it unusual
to go
that long without checking
he always lets me know when he needs
something so i didn't think anything of
it sure when we return we'll get an
answer as to what actually happened to
sterling i didn't really even challenge
cheyenne in the interview i didn't know
the condition of sterling at the time we
had no idea it was far worse than that
we're going to be looking at your house
and we're going to be taking things from
the guys so this is number
to get to get you guys the truth and the
answers that you need
in 2017 zachary keane and his girlfriend
cheyenne harris tell police they were
shocked to find their four-month-old son
sterling dead in his swing
harris would explain to investigator
chris callaway that she fed sterling
how many feedings would sterling have a
day
but normally it would be three or four
of the eight ounce things okay
and sterling's room seemed to be fine
how warm was the room
it was comfortable
and it didn't seem too hot to me
yet it soon becomes clear that things
aren't adding up and that the couple who
struggled with substance abuse hadn't
checked on sterling for quite some time
i didn't have any preconceived notions
about what had happened and as she
started talking i was just left with
that
that uh
that gap in in time i mean so we're
looking at 19 hours with no care of a
newborn
if you were to
predict what the doctors will find what
do you think
let's not keep saying
sorry about sudden death syndrome okay
overall wasn't very well thought through
this just doesn't add up with with
sudden infant death syndrome there's
something else to know about sterling's
death
something that would make this case
stand out from many others
sterling wasn't just found dead in his
swing
but his room was in fact extremely hot
and smelled of urine
and one of the most disturbing
revelations
the infant's diaper was filled with
maggots
sterling was taken to our state medical
examiner's office where an autopsy was
done and cause of death was denial of
critical care
and
the manner of death was was considered
homicide he i believe was an etymologist
who spoke extensively about you know the
fact that the flies that and the maggots
that were on baby sterling's body he was
able to track back and say you know
listen based on where the eggs were in
their development how the flies were in
their development we can say that you
know this had been going on and this
child had been in the state for close to
two weeks how did the child stay in a
swing for two weeks without diaper being
changed anyone checking on him
that's just beyond the pale according to
the autopsy sterling died from a
combination of malnutrition dehydration
and an e coli infection
ultimately both keene and harris were
arrested and charged with first degree
murder and child endangerment i think
that drug use along with mental health
contributed to this but i think it goes
deeper than that with this couple
there is an absolute lack of empathy
towards their child you could argue that
there's some
disorder or that they're disturbed
mentally
but there's also an element of evil here
it takes conscious effort
to do this
up next keane and harris each go to
trial and try to convince jurors they're
not murderers
[Music]
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again judge
caprio rules with common sense i was
having contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime is
the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the long crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is law and crime
how has
sterling's appetite been
the last
day
a couple days
near feedings
okay
in iowa parents zachary keene and
cheyenne harris are facing murder and
child endangerment charges in connection
with the death of their four-month-old
son sterling
forensic evidence including the presence
of maggots in the infant's diaper
suggests sterling hadn't been fed nor
changed in two weeks and was left to die
in his swing
the couple were tried separately
first up was keen
little sterling couldn't feed himself
he couldn't
change his diaper
he was vulnerable as only an infant can
be
evidence in this case will show by his
actions
he directly caused sterling's death
he told the dispatcher that his son had
died of sids or sudden infant death in
them that's not what happened in this
case
this was not an accident
that was a cover story concocted by this
defendant
to cover the awful truth
and he's going to talk about the
evidence
why this is a tragedy
but not a crime
we're going to ask you
to return a verdict
in a case with such horrid details many
wondered how could the defense explain
this away
well zachary keene himself tried to do
just that when he took the stand
[Music]
cheyenne harris the mother
were you at any time
i
trust your judgment i mean
look at my daughter she's very
healthy and so i trust her
he totally was blaming her and being
like i trusted the wrong person at the
end of the day it's both of you because
you're both the parents and you both
live in this tiny house him trying to
blame her and her trying to blame him
just made the jury more enraged state of
iowa versus zachary kane
verdi form count one we the jury the
violent defendant
guilty of murder in the first degree
count two we the jury find the defendant
guilty of child endangerment causing the
death of a child
then there was cheyenne harris's trial
that this is not a case where the parent
miss harris lacked resources or was an
inexperienced parent
the other child in the home
her name is nala the evidence will show
that she was healthy
in contrast to thrilling
in contrast to sterling she was properly
clothed and cleaned and bathed
she was properly fed
that child's mother
cheyenne harris
failed in her responsibility as a parent
she failed little sterling
she violated the trust that sterling
placed in her as her mother
you're going to wonder what kind of
monster could do something like this
the monster in this case is mental
health
the monster in this case is depression
postpartum
substance abuse
she's not evil and this is this case is
not murder
it was an extremely difficult case to
try
i think it was a situation where
cheyenne was suffering from postpartum
depression as well as substance abuse
and then adding in a father who wasn't
claiming this baby
and so i think that's why the older
child nala
was
cared for and the younger child was kind
of just left to the side
and it just smiled down from there i
certainly had evidence of the use of
methamphetamine or prolonged use of
methamphetamine myth causing that
disconnect
and you lose your understanding of time
shows that she was really disconnected
from reality they didn't have anything
to show that she had actual hate for
this child or any reason to suspect that
she wanted the baby to die
we the jury find the defendant
guilty of murder in the first degree we
the jury find the defendant guilty of
child endangerment causing the death of
a child
we were hamstrung by
iowa's felony murder rule
as it relates to
a certain form of child endangerment if
it's proven that they don't have to
prove premeditation
and what that did is it gutted our
ability to argue anything along the
lines of specific intent they don't like
the felony murder rule murder should be
reserved for the worst of the worst and
cheyenne is far from that
both harris and keane were sentenced to
life in prison and at the time of this
taping each of their appeals have been
shot down
it's never going to bring sterling back
it's never going to diminish the
the horrendous miserable
last days of his life
but you can hold uh
zack and cheyenne accountable and
in a small case prevent this from ever
happening again it's tough to work these
types of cases but it is important that
the truth comes out
cheyenne harris and zachary keene failed
to show their infant son the attention
and care he deserved yet as they sit in
prison seemingly for the rest of their
lives you have to imagine that sterling
will be on their minds
day
after day
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
primecrime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
[Music]
you